we very rarely start right off with a
guest but we make exceptions for those
who deserve it and for those who we
particularly like and I'm gonna stop
talking about the guy who was sitting
next to me to my right like he's not
here he is uh along with the Tommy
Curran is that how you say his name out
there in New England yeah I mean twice
that could use a little work along with
Tom Curran who's straight out of how do
you like them apples
central Cass no it's Edelman kid right
on the right on the set he is Julian
Edelman right here on the set good to
see you good to see you guys relentless
is your book relentless and I see on the
back you've got quotes from Robert Kraft
Bill Belichick and Tom Brady how'd you
get those guys to give you quotes you
know uh don't you get those guys took me
nine years to ask them for something and
this is the one thing that you never
asked anything of those guys huh never
not assigned Jersey ones from Tom okay
bill absolutely nothing mr. Kraft now
mr. Kraft rkk he wants me to call him
rkk but it he just can't do it
you can't bring yourself a well he's
he's technically uh my boss I mean he's
in charge of broadcast opportunities I
guess for the National Football League
get they and and the NFL Network would
not exist without him I call him Bobby
the K is that is that a little bit
disrespectful what do you think no he's
a pretty he's an easygoing guy
you can he's calm cool and collected you
call him anything so uh guess what I
don't call him what Bobby the K yeah I
probably wouldn't I was just trying to
make you sugarcoat it
the sugarcoat no rich that's what we do
why do you call it relentless why'd you
come up with that one Julian it's
because it's essentially it's about my
story and my persona of how I've had to
be to get to where I'm at mm-hmm you
know what I mean um you know uh all the
adversity and injuries all the knows I
had to overcome give me some examples
some of the knows that you had overcome
that's in this book here well you know I
whenever we were getting recruited out
of high school you know they bring all
like
Stud football players in the room and
that colleges would come in and no one
ever really looked at me and then you
know then you go to JUCO and you weren't
supposed to go play Division one
quarterback anywhere and then you know
after Ken you know trying to transition
as a as a quarterback to play receiver
the National Football League you know a
lot of people said hey you know he it's
gonna be a long road for him and that's
kinda how it's always been I've always
had to take the long road and it's
always been a bumpy one but it's always
been a fun one Julian Edelman here on
the Rich Eisen show to kick things off
on a Friday in New York City we always
hear about Tom's draft day experience
yeah or draft days experience then the
Brady six documentary so many people
were taken aback that it still brings
him to tears years after he has pretty
much one life at this point in time as a
40 year old man hashtag killin it
hashtag killing it okay so what was your
draft day his experience my draft day um
I had I had a few buddies over I go real
depth on rich in the book every real
depth well keep it a little bridge okay
but I had my friends family there and we
were just sitting there and I was
watching it and the six-round came and
we were anticipating potentially you
know late rounds or priority free agent
and a bunch of teams started hitting up
my agent saying hey we want you to sign
his undrafted free agent will give you
some money here there we ultimately
almost you know we made the decision at
the time you know out of all the teams
that offered us a contract that if we
were gonna go that route we were gonna
go with the Packers but then my agent
Don you know he's he's kind of like a
real Donnie's a real I know Don here
yeah you know Don around these yeah he's
a real like mellow like monotone kind of
guy yeah he goes you know Jules Patriots
they just traded got to seventh round
picks it wouldn't surprise me if you go
there but I'll call you back babe um
looks like we're gonna be a packer
everybody like you know and then you
know then all of a sudden I get a call
from a 500 or
number block number and it was bearish
who's like oh he's right he's Bella
checks right right yeah right handing
you know he we're gonna draft you
and so here's bill and and then bill
came on on the phone and basically said
you know we don't know what you're gonna
play but uh yeah you could play bossy
and rookie minicamp here's Nancy and
that was that was my draft day and your
head had to be spinning at that point it
was spinning I I mean it was it was
great you know all your friends come
over and and everyone's celebrating
everything but then a big wall hits you
like alright so that I'm talking to my
agent there's 90 guys on the team right
now like they're only keeping 53 mm-hmm
then reality sets in like you got to
make a team and and that's kind of how
it's always been with me no like alright
it's great but there's a huge you know
plan that we got going but let's just
worry about we got on our plate right
now and and and kind of give all my time
and energy into the goal I have at that
time and at that time I was just trying
to make a team right and then now
obviously where you are in your career
if you had to tell somebody
again relentless is the book and I don't
want to give away too much of what's in
there because I don't want to obviously
hear it from Tom Curren that what would
you tell somebody why you are the player
man you are today with that journey
being the beginning with that kid who
got drafted heard from bear the the
Bears fell a check Nancy trio on that
draft day the seventh round um yeah I
think a lot of it has to do with with my
father you know how he raised me and how
how tough he was on me with with
everything you know whether it was
baseball season you know taking the
baton balls to the lake on vacations and
taking batting practice there having my
sister at first catching oh I do infield
or basketball when it was rainy and we'd
go to the gym he'd rent out this a
little half-court gym and shoot for five
hours or it was football you know we're
in the middle of the street and he's
putting out rocks
telling me which holes which hole you
know and making me do all these kind of
things you know running through them and
catch in and all these that are throwing
you know I think all those things along
with you know here in the word know a
lot created a chip on my shoulder
that that has helped me get to where I'm
at I mean everywhere I was always at you
know there's always a group of guys on
the team and I wasn't that guy that was
supposed to make it I was always he's a
good guy he's a good player you know and
he's a easy
he works hard and he's got some athletic
ability but this guy right here he's
gonna go you know even on the Patriots
you ran into that at some point ah
I mean first four years yeah you're
playing behind people you know that
Welker right you yeah you playing buying
a lot of guys and and Wes was one of
them and so it's it's just a story about
you know obstacles overcoming them
adversity mindset and and you know
basically how I became the way I am I do
Julian Edelman here I'm with the
ultimate respect you know how much I
respect you right I do remember when you
first burst on the scene you were the
mini Welker you're like okay like you
you're there's Welker there's also
Edelman yeah you know and then when
Welker left it's just like I don't know
how he's gonna fill the shoes of Wes
Welker I don't know how that's possible
that was the conversation yeah for sure
it's it's kind of weird that I was mini
Welker when I'm an inch taller and ten
pounds heavy twelve well I mean I don't
I know but it's always been check the
height and weight yeah it's you know I
was always someone else so but hey I'm
not complaining doesn't matter how you
get there it's matter you got there how
were you as a baseball player did you
have that ability to I was I was I could
play baseball we're we're all field I
was short I was shortstop I can't play
anywhere though I can pitch um can
control it what do you think of Altuve
unbeliev what you stud right just a
little stud
any guys anytime a guy can can perform
like that under high pressure situations
and at the ultimate you know stage
that's just--that's water going through
his veins ice-cold water are you saying
that - because he beat the Yankees as
well is that the is that a Boston New
York thing but no probably have coursing
through your veins and you know it's
more of just a respect factor for his
his his play and you know it was good to
see Huston win let's just say that I
grew up in the Bay Area so there we go
oh okay so that's Dodger hate because
you're a Giants fan is that where I'm
trying to connect the dots right here
hey you know I'm a Boston Giants guy
okay Austin and SF Giants okay there you
go Sox and Giants learning about Julian
Edelman right here let's take a break
when we come back I want to talk to you
about the the main headline of yesterday
which is deshaun Watson now getting set
to go through what you're currently
going through right now coming back from
a knee injury also wanna hit you on a
couple other subjects around the
National Football League and I don't
know if you saw your coach shut down a
reporter this week did he yeah who dared
to ask a yes or no question which is the
worst thing I keep telling members of
the media do not go to Bill Belichick
with a yes-or-no question I don't even
ask him questions I get paid to actually
try to ask him questions yeah I know
I hear you it really is uh it's pretty
it's a priceless moment right because
the guy that we think the guy looks like
Ellis from dying from die hard you
remember me and I think he wound up with
a similar fate with Bill Belichick is
Hans Gruber that's coming up next here
on this edition with the Rich Eisen show
Julian Edelman Bill Cowher after that
and then we'll we'll turn our attention
to the rest of the sports world and take
your phone calls at eight four four two
oh four rich is the number to dial here
on this busy Friday from New York City
edition of the Rich Eisen show before we
chat with Julian again I want to tell
you all about Indochina on if you've
heard about this Julian you are
definitely a man who likes to dress for
success always I know that dress to
success you have you have number one
number one we see I've seen you come off
those private jets Julie and I've seen
those photographs
julian edelman x' book relentless is
available wherever books are sold right
now how is your knee look update can you
get me on your okay you're gonna ask
well what mustache mullet how is your
mustache and where is your mullet sir
I'm working on the mullet yeah that's
how much party in the back right now I
gotta be honest with you little party
though I got a kid now so you keep it
little parties that really yeah yeah so
she's she's one year old now right
daughter she's about to be one this
month but the mustache is great okay
great um what do you think of my beard I
mean they said this is the guy that's
the conversation I really wanna have
that's a good looking beard thank you
it's all I've got
yeah you got a take where you can get it
well that's one way to look at it I was
about to say my wife really likes it a
lot I'm getting texts during Thursday
Night Football never get from my wife
she never digs it but right now my wife
if she saw this two-shot right now I
think I would lose I think I would
absolutely you should mention that
Richie just texted me oh my god is it
wrong that I was jealous of Cooper this
morning yeah because you facetimed with
my son Cooper oh man she was the one
literally holding the phone I told her
not one bit he's good he's good
I got an ACL now so that's that's all
matters okay you know now the
interesting cuz
deshaun Watson goes terrible straight my
hearts out to that guy man he's been
playing great football young early but
uh with the way and and hearing from
people that I know over there kind of
guy he is I think he's gonna be all
right now Marshall Faulk um who was on
the set last night on Thursday Night
Football on the NFL Network with me and
he's had knee surgeries before his first
reaction when he sees what he said on
the air is that the thing that DeSean is
gonna have to deal with the most is the
solitude that was the first thing you
said the solitude of being by yourself
while you're rehabbing away from your
teammates you agree with that yeah a
hundred percent I mean it that's the
thing that people don't realize injuries
I mean they suck and everything but it's
it's the the mental side of it that that
really gets you because you're putting
all this time and effort all year long
for the season and then all the sudden
is taken away from you and you know
you're part of the team but you're
really not you know what I mean the team
goes to meetings you're going to rehab
you know you're you're rehab and you'll
see the guys in the hallway or not
you're not fully into it I mean I'll you
go to some meetings here and there but
like your main mission is to get your
body back so you know with with him I
mean it'll probably be different but uh
Wow he's a quarterback quarterback you
got to stay in - and he's young he's you
know younger in there so see I never
understood that because Mark McGwire
told me years ago when I was covering
baseball at ESPN that when he got hurt
he didn't want to be around the team
team didn't want to be around him and I
thought to myself when you're covering
team sports it's a brotherhood but when
somebody gets hurt isn't that when the
Brotherhood is needed the most well you
get it you get it with certain guys it's
freezing in here guys I know you know
the thing you were in that's that really
sweet jacket it's a nice jacket
what is that pleather leather what are
you guys I don't know what it is it's
not leather though it's like a UH like a
cowhide almost or something you know
what it it what is this I know what it
is I'll answer cherries Nigeria I'll
answer for Gerry
it's called expensive jeans jeans a
great great jacket all right I'm sorry
you're cold this we're talking about
solitude now he's cold like he's not
he's rehabbing now he's gonna have the
flu and it's cold in here
it's it sucks because it's kind of like
the racecar driver who crashes the other
guys don't really want to talk to him
because they don't want to jinx it and
then also you know you don't know what
to say to a guy when he's hurt hey get
in there we miss you but like
realistically you got to move on you're
moving on from that because the Train
always moves on so who are you talking
to
I mean I'll talk to Brady I'll talk to
guys I'll go to the receiver room and
hang out with the fellas Kooks oh I mean
I see them all I poked my head in all
the time and
you know it's different I've been around
for a while but uh earlier in my career
when you get hurt it's kind of it's it's
a lonely place it still is you know um
you're not with the guys so you know it
definitely it's a mental battle but like
I said from what I've heard with with
the Shawn I mean I've heard the kids a
solid guy and he's very motivated and
he's got some real professional traits
so you know you wish him the best luck
in his recovery as I'm doing on Julian
Edelman here in the Rich Eisen show how
are you taking in the games what are you
doing on game day so it's it sucks
because you know you have all your
friends and family and they all plan
like months and ahead you know I'm
coming to this game coming to this game
come to this game and like so they all
come to the games and and then you end
up getting hurt so I'll go entertain
them for a little bit like the first
half and and after being asked the same
question 500 times how's the knee what
are you what's the plan this that can we
have a pit like after doing that for
like a half I usually leave and watch
watch it at home or listen to it in the
car
damn yeah and then away games I just
chill I have like a couple buddies over
and well watched you scream at the
screen or scream at the announcers that
they don't know what do you do
I literally it I can't watch football
now it's ruined me when you play here in
the league or at least where I play why
the whole time I'm sitting there
critiquing like alright what would I do
against this coverage alright
oh they're in this formation against
this so I know they're doing this oh
he's gonna check it here because there's
two safe you know like you're just
basically breaking the game down you're
trying to stay mentally sharp I don't
know if I'm trying to stay mentally
sharp it's just naturally what I do like
you know oh I know right here on this
third down probably man coverage against
this team right here single high they're
gonna drive you know they're gonna have
someone drop out and you know you just
you're just playing the game in your
head you can't enjoy it it's up yeah I'm
the kind of the same way to be honest
with you with watching from a broadcast
yeah you
I'm here I'm always trying to get better
at my craft even though um you know
20-some odd years into it so for
instance if I was a patriot beat writer
I would not go to Bill Belichick with a
yes-or-no question ever try to get him
to talk about the history of the game or
or somebody's military military or what
does this guy remind you of who does he
remind you of who Edelman remind you of
not like hey how are you guys going to
score without Edelman do you think do or
do you think the offense will be as
productive without Edelman like that
sort of question you are just gonna get
shut down so here after the Patriots
recent win over the Los Angeles chargers
can we play for Julian Edelman play this
Q a with again the guy that we saw on
Twitter somebody said it reminded him of
Ellis on die hard go for it roll it for
Julianne coach the game was played
predominantly in the teens is that a
game a style that you're comfortable
playing what are you talking about
well not scoring a lot of points not
high-flying offense necessarily more low
scoring grind it out is that a style you
like the team prefers I would prefer to
with
[Music]
build the I've actually gotten that from
what the head the head yeah
uh under what circumstance see you
you're saying you feel for the reporter
right there no I mean he knows what he's
getting into
he's really getting into but coach is
just he's an intense guy he's intense
and like he's one tract mm-hmm and that
tract is moving forward not being asked
are you are you comfortable playing
games in that I mean really what kind of
question it's a terrible question it's
so be I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to like I don't know I'm not I don't
like do you like winning games a little
or say this is probably where his
mindset is that's the fourth straight
game not scoring 30 or more points it's
the longest Oh stretch in 15 seasons
that's where hit that question was good
then he should he should have broke it
down like that probably right probably I
don't know coach now I know you've got a
killer Belichick impersonation you did
it the last time on the show you were
concerned about it
the Patriots website posted it okay so
that is a stamp of approval damp of
approval so I'm gonna do this you may
say no but I'd like you to read the Bill
Belichick blurb that he wrote on the
back of relentless in Bill Belichick
voice you're promoting your book it is
what he said Julian Edelman is going to
read the Bill Belichick inscription on
the back of his book as Bill Belichick
please go oh man do it you got uh coach
like I said sorry last time here we go
well um what what Julian has done from
the time years entered the league is
nothing short of remarkable
he is the epitome of competitiveness
toughness and great things that are
possibly when so possible when somebody
is determinate achieve goals that's true
that's join yeah next question
it's okay Tilly Kapital again you're
fine man
Brady wrote like a whole paragraph man
Brady's in it
he's in it of course he's talking in it
too yeah in the book he is about talking
about avocados and stuff like that or
not okay talking about competitiveness
whining games Julian you are you're an
inspiration a lot of people man
certainly those little kids in my
household you know my wife was watching
the pursues he was watching a patreon
the other day she just saw she goes man
I just miss settlement plan I appreciate
a lot of Patriots fans feel that way I
feel that every Sunday a lot of Patriots
fans feel that way you know when I when
I sit back and and do like YouTube
videos and and all these content things
you're an inspiration to meet you rich
you're a true inspiration is your tongue
firmly planted in your cheek right there
what are you talking about are you
serious you're being serious I mean this
is inspirational stuff you guys this is
this is a one here based in LA and then
they come to New York and in like they
don't even miss a beat well let me tell
you something I mean I saw them like
they change his whole room ya know there
was a second it was truly like a well
that's just the great fear of from AT&T
and DirecTV here in in in lower
Manhattan bill calories are on the on
the phone line I'm gonna take a break
and get to him before the red zone
DirecTV two shows but but before I let
you go we have a relationship with Funny
or Die they are making videos for this
show if you want to be in one or you
have an idea for one
let's I'm serious we talk we are you an
idea guy we are well but is it an idea I
did I just say it's a New England thing
people are on idea I say idea and I
don't say jagwire either I say Jaguar
Jaguar
yeah there's no W and I'm not a Jaguar
you know what you should do what I got a
pop-up shop that I'm sellin relentless
in in Boston this weekend a 333 Newbury
Street there you go you could take coupe
Taylor but they're there in Zen their
ends and they're in there in Southern
California
oh when you've got a pop-up shop so in
SoCal you let me know all right just in
case maybe next time we're serving
burgers in line people are in line whole
family's there
I mean I'll send my I'll send my
brother-in-law and his kids you're
looking a hat you got it good to see you
sir relentless with Julian Edelman go
get it right now for more Rich Eisen
show tuned to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Rich Eisen show
app